[Music]
good morning today we're heading to
hakone we've been there before it's an
hour and a half from tokyo it's usually
like a relaxing place it's where i
propose to marcia we're gonna do some
touristy stuff
and then some stuff we already done
before because we it's a really nice
place this is the first time we didn't
realize it until we were like oh yeah
this is the first time in three years we
spent the night away from the dogs just
because i've covered in the trip we just
never been able to do it so we're free
at last
just chill and have fun
[Music]
we made a quick stop to pick up some
food
it's a lot busier than i thought it
would be
i don't know if it's a holiday or
something i thought it would be empty
like a lot of places but not hot corner
it's fun though so many shops and stuff
so yeah we're heading to the
spa place now
and we're gonna have lunch there
[Music]
we're here in the mountains it's a lot
cooler here it feels really good
ah
nature hydrangeas hydrangeas
hydrogen yes did you know that they
changed their color based on soil so
what does bloom mean
oh really you knew that hiring iron
that's so cool i mean that's what my mom
said according to myself
whoa okay that's that's what we're doing
i told you it was a bit touristy so we
obviously have
tattoos but as long as we cover up it
should be okay i have no idea where the
entrance is we're just oh there it is
i read it
no big deal oh so cute
so that's our mascot
go marcia going for the sunfish
i don't even see it
[Music]
watch this
two of them
easy
five of them
oh that's bad
oh
let's go
so cute
you know i love smirking
i smoke every day this is so big
looks like i'm naked we're at a more
like a ryokan kind of setting but we're
still in a swimsuit because we're inside
the building it's really nice no one's
here
protein
pure
purest form it looks nice
they got fishies
which is kind of odd
[Applause]
[Music]
wow what a
mermaid
we're in coffee
this is weird
fatigue recovery
skin benefit
but don't drink it
this one is nice
i think i killed my phone it's not
turning on
i thought it was waterproof mane
what can you do we're gonna do the slime
now it's so pretty it's raining oh my
god
[Music]
oh he's so dead
please live
come back online please thank you
[Music]
do you remember
so we were trying to ride this train
because i wanted us to go in the cable
cart
this is the day i proposed to marzia
and we
ran into a trouble in like a ticket
counter because they didn't speak
english i didn't know any japanese and
they were closing and i don't know what
he was trying to tell me
and marcel was like it's fine we don't
have to do it because it seemed
impossible but i was like no
we have to do it because i knew
obviously that i was going to propose
for marcy didn't so
i wanted us to have a good day and we
made it it was super nice
we've been selling fuji
all the way up it all worked out
how could you it's because we went
swimming okay where's the excuse
this is what we in sweden call
small grant like explosion green
it's nice you know what we're gonna do
i'm gonna cook my phone oh
i have my custom klvp theme i put so
much time in today's
i don't want to lose this theme i made
okay so now you should play the clip
that broke the phone and then you tell
me if it was worth it
[Music]
all right let's see it
[Music]
oh that was close
ah
yay
i love their choice of puzzles
[Music]
cooking my thumb what's the problem
everyone does it
it actually looks kind of good on me
yeah maybe i'll keep this
[Music]
we're heading to the open air museum
we've been here once before we peed in
sophie it was really cool it's so cloudy
though rainy season finally came huh my
phone is dead there's no revival i was
actually looking for a new phone the
other day and i feel like my phone got
jealous and was like fine i'll just die
then and then when it did arrive and
come back for a little bit i was like
i'm gonna buy a new phone anyway and you
were like that's so mean and then he
quit he and then he quit
i killed it
[Music]
[Music]
i remember being
get a picture here
you can go all the way up
damn that's cool
that's a cool shot
hello
what
uh
it still looks cool with it
i'm out of breath
amazing
should i drop your phone and break it
too
so nice
it's so hot it's lovely
we did it during winter last time and i
was like yes
i'm cooking
so
[Music]
i got it
i think two hours
why i don't know why it took so long but
we got it that's so good
yeah
so the phone came back
like 30 minutes yesterday and i managed
to back up the footage
so we're good on that front but
the phone is dead so i need to buy
another one basically
[Music]
we're in asakusa which is like old tokyo
it's super pretty i was like coming here
but it's very busy i want to go there
mars is feeling something so today is
supposed to be the last day of the
festival the thing that i showed earlier
with the paper and the bamboo
technically is cancelled
but we think they will do it
they'll still be decorations and stuff
but the actual festival isn't going on
there it is there's a big temple
this is so cool i'm just walking just
chilling freaking dog with me
it's ridiculous
i remember going here the day after i
proposed to marcia and it was the same
kind of vibe actually but i never
thought i'd be here with the this one
[Music]
andrea
and just there's my favorite pagoda
so pretty
this air is crazy
i forgot
everything is so pretty
damn
everywhere you look it looks so
aesthetic
that was definitely not your everyday
kind of walk with the dogs
[Music]
damn they got some gay aries
i like it this is the street
there's the sky tree so yeah it's
definitely cancelled
but
it's still cool to see this area really
feels like what you'd imagine
when you think about japan
[Music]
how do you like it my aunt she's a
little tired now
[Music]
we're in mbc
looking for a place to eat oh yeah they
have gundam at mcdonald's i saw this
today
yes
gundam burger what do you get if you get
to build your burger like a gundam
that'd be kind of sick but i doubt it i
never get used to how many people there
are it almost shocks me whenever we go
out it's like oh damn a lot of good food
places here and a lot of good uh
bars here i like it so it's cool look at
this
i almost died
but i'm alive
i will make it to the shrine
such a cool shot
real reason i moved to japan is so i can
feel tall
at last i'm a giant
[Music]
wish for my uh to become healthy
forgot how crazy it is
i know this bit because i play persona 4
and you walk this way in the subway so i
already am familiar
so i asked
uh like oh what kind of stuff do you
guys want to see on the channel
and people are like oh just do let's do
what you want
let's do what you want to do i saw a
couple of people saying that yeah just a
hubra
you guys are so nice it's supposed to
work out
i'm not feeling good today since i'm
always sharing happy fun moment i
thought i'd share a little uh down i
just need to get this workout then i was
feeling bad before but now i'm starting
to feel better so i'm gonna do it no
more excuses can you guys tell the
difference on the camera by the way so i
have the new phone now i do feel kind of
like a genius for
backing up the footage back up your
footage this is a reminder you don't
want to lose it i'm just procrastinating
now
so i was in the shop and i was like what
what protein powder flavor is this i was
hoping they would say banana
but it's ocha it's a green tea
let's give it a try maybe it's good
how much protein is in there
oh
20 gram 28 grams is 20 grams see i
learned the kanjis that matter okay
cheers
it's actually pretty good
i'm so surprised well done japan
that's really good
the other option was like lemon i'm like
no or chocolate i never like chocolate
and protein shakes
right what's going on here
usually you're barking like crazy at
this hour but you kind of
you just look a little pissed off to be
honest
you're not so angry well we'll see how
she develops but
my uh has pedimentis
she's so old her mind is kind of
declining a bit
sorry i'm saying it in front of everyone
you're almost 17. you're not angry today
yeah i guess today's a good day
tomorrow is an even better day
tomorrow one of my dreams come true big
earthquake just hit
that was so quick
that was so intense
that's the heaviest one i thought it's
so quick though
my i didn't even flinch i bet that was
nothing i don't do earthquakes as a
swede um
no
squeeze then
b minus tier workout now we shall
[Music]
today oh what a day what a beautiful day
a dream of mine come true today
i've always wanted to surf in japan
and guess what i'm doing today
surf in japan i'm gonna take a lesson
because
i've only done it twice before and it's
been years ago at this point so i'm very
very very excited
[Music]
okay
[Music]
look at this black one
that's so pretty
damn
i am
sunburned
that was intense workout i'm pretty
spent
three hours so fun though
he uh he didn't really baby me he kind
of let me just
try all the waves myself and pick them
and
yeah really fun i'm not built for this
sun though
i bathed in sunscreen before but i think
it all just kind of washed off right
away
the waves are so intense
and i burned my feet
but it was really fun i think i might
try it on my own next time
i burned my foot oh that feels good
do not walk on hot sand
[Music]
i was so proud of myself for this
that's my teacher there
i picked away myself i wrote it all away
but it looks so
tame
i felt so incredible at that moment
it was kind of rough it was hard to find
waves and that were rideable my board
was so long that it took so long to
rotate in time and i missed a lot of
ways because of it it is
uh the third time i ever try it i i'm
stoked i was so fun actual dream come
true to be doing it as well my teacher
was really good and he let me do it on
my own and feel like i was the one doing
it sometimes teachers kind of get too
much i think but it was also one thing
he said that i thought was really good
which i missed one wave and then he said
and i said like oh damn and he said
don't don't do that because you want to
just enjoy it that's a good point i
can't wait to do it again i'll be
catching waves soon again
oh that's cold
oh that feels good though
oh oh mama
okay
[Music]
you're so cute
are you sleepy
as at least it's not covered
but you can hear my voice it's like
i'm congested since i'm a bit down under
the weather today it might be a good
time to chat a bit uh i just wanted to
say a huge thanks huge thanks for all
the support and positivity and the
comments everyone seems to love the
vlogs and it's a huge reason why i'm
even doing them i mean it's fun for us
to look back on
as well i think but usually
me and mars are a bit more private with
our private life because there's always
so much annoyance coming with sharing
your life online i don't that's the
easiest way to describe it but
everyone's just been so nice supportive
and positive and yeah that makes me want
to share more and i really appreciate it
maybe some people will think it's like
oh everyone's just so positive and
so kisses whatever but i don't know i'll
take it i feel like i've gotten my fair
share of people complaining and you know
how it is it's almost like to someone
i'm always doing something wrong so if
people are being supported i
will take it i'm done with all the
negative
[ __ ] drama i've been for a while but
i think here just uh transitioning here
it's been really fun just focus on
focusing on fun stuff huge thanks to
marzia for editing these vlogs i think
that's what makes them so
special so i'm still editing my other
videos we just figured it's easier and
it makes sense for her to do it and
she's doing a great job as well so it's
funny how a lot of you guys seem to have
noticed too like oh they have their
style to it and i i think it works out
great so yeah thank you marks yeah i'm
always kind of cur
cautious with doing vlogs because just
the sharing aspect online it opens up so
much judgment but also i've daily vlog
before and that can be fun for a little
bit but it can also sort of become like
your life becomes your job or something
like that but i think we've been keeping
it natural it hasn't been forced or
we're just doing stuff that we like to
do and there's so much to do here and
it's so much fun but also just having
the freedom to be out and about here
pretty much undisturbed i really enjoy
that it feels very liberating to be here
and yeah i think that reflects in the
vlog so again
huge thanks to you guys i really really
really really appreciate it honestly i
think i'll feel better later today we'll
see
i got leg day today can't skip leg day